hey guys today is the 7th of September
my name is just you're watching games
but news and here the important stuff
whether you love him or hate him Felix
PewDiePie Kilberg is a super popular guy
and he's just hit a massive YouTube
milestone the controversial YouTube
celebrity just became the first user to
surpass 10 million views on his channel
PewDiePie posted to Twitter today we
made history 10 billion views this is
insane thank you all so much the
youtuber has previously made comments
about how unsettling he finds his
popularity but it continues to be pretty
awesome that a primarily gaming focused
channel is the most popular thing on
YouTube Bundy recently lost a lawsuit
with former composer Marty O'Donnell and
a closer look at the court documents for
the trial have revealed some pretty
interesting destiny development tidbit
included in these documents is the claim
that the games seven months delay was
caused by changes made to the narrative
it says although destiny was planned for
a lease in September 2013 the story was
substantially revised at beginning all
this 2013 requiring a new release date
of March 2014 and edits too much of the
work previously completed since a lot of
players want fans of the story it seems
like it might not have hurt to leave it
as it was a lot of the dissatisfaction
with the game's narrative came from
bungees pre-release assurance that the
game would have rich law comparable to
that of Star Wars Lord of the Rings and
Harry Potter the majority of this law
was seemingly cut out of the game and
only made accessible via bungees website
finally former president of Xbox Robbie
bark has called the company struggles
under his successor Don Mattrick both
predictable and preventable Barker
previously led the Microsoft division
responsible for the releases of the xbox
and xbox 360 suggested to GeekWire that
the always-on internet requirement and
RM implications were pretty big misstep
bark wasn't completely dismissive of the
team though saying I can be a little
critical I could also say the team did
what they needed to do they persevere
through a rocky patch and they're now on
the path to making this a very
competitive market park added that he
thinks digital-only consoles will be the
future saying that the next generation
of hardware will probably not have
physical media let me know down in the
comments if you think digital-only
consoles are going to be the future or
not and why you can add the games but
we've got stories on the villains the
star wars episode 8 and pikmin for being
announced that is everything I have for
you today as always let me know what you
cared about and they will catch you
tomorrow